High tax rates damage Britain's
competitiveness they reduced the
incentive to work to invest and to start
a business and the higher the tax the
more ways people seek to avoid them or
work elsewhere or simply work less
but I'm not going to cut the additional
rate of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
from April the 23rd we will have the
high a single higher rate of income tax
of 40 percent this will simplify the tax
system and make Britain more competitive
it'll reward and surprise and work it
will incentivize growth it'll benefit
the whole economy and the whole country
and Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
after all after all this only returns us
this only returns us to the top rate we
had for 20 years including the entire
time the opposition was lost in power
for one month for one month and that's
not all I can announce today that we
will cut the basic rate of income tax to
19 pence in April 2023 one year earlier
that means a tax cut for over 31 million
people in just a few months time this
means that we will have one of the most
competitive and pro-growth income tax
systems in the world